bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien de
l'intelligence économique l'émission
consacrée aux coulisses de la
mondialisation cette fois faut-il croire
les élites politiques et économiques
vont elles enfin
réindustrialiser la france est peut-être
plus largement l'europe des années que
certains prêchent dans le désert jusqu'à
ce que nous prenions la réalité en
pleine figure lors de la crise sanitaire
et les ruptures d'approvisionnement qui
ont suivi pour en parler je reçois anaïs
voix gillis chercheuse rattaché à
l'université de poids de poitiers et
publie un article sur la
réindustrialisation de la france dans la
revue des cahiers français bonjour anaïs
voix gillis première question alors
faut-il croire ou pas
bonjour
bien entendu qu'il ya des raisons ni
croire à cette ré industrialisation par
contre il faut se dire que c'est un
chemin qui va être quand même assez
complexe et coûteux puisque on sort
venir dans ce schéma de 30 à 40 ans de
désindustrialisation et donc la
réindustrialisation cd reconstruire
notre tissu productif qui va passer à la
fois par l'implantation nouvelle
activité la roue densification
du tissu existant et éventuellement le
rapatriement de certaines activités va
prendre du temps mais il faut y croire
sinon si on n'y croit pas et bien on
n'arrivera jamais enclenché ce mouvement
alors on se fait d'abord d'accord sur
les mots sur les termes est-ce qu'il
faut parler de
réindustrialisation de
relocalisation qu'est-ce qu'il faut
utiliser comme terme
moi j'ai tendance à dire ce qu'on a
tendance à dire opposé
réindustralisation être localisation la
relocalisation c'est quoi c'est le fait
de rapatrier sur le territoire national
des entreprises qui est des activités
qui était au préalable et qui ont été
transférées vers d'autres pays mais dans
la relocalisation peut aussi parler de
localisation c'est-à-dire locales y
revenir localisée sur le territoire
français des activités qui n'y ont
jamais été c'est par exemple le cas de
l'entreprise l'uni qui fabrique des
boîtes à histoires des jouets pour
enfants qui a produit ces jouets en
chine et qui grâce à un travail est
assez important sur son produit est bien
est venu rapatrier cette production sur
le territoire national et la
réindustrialisation et bien elle peut
englober la relocalisation elle pas
englober la localisation d'activités
c'est tout simplement le fait est bien
de redonner un dynamisme industriel à un
territoire qui est s'est
désindustrialisée c'est-à-dire
redensifier la base industrielle donc
les deux ne s'oppose pas contrairement à
ce qu'on a tendance à faire et bien il
faut bien dire que la relocalisation est
une des composantes de la
réindustrialisation de la france alors
550 projets de relocalisation
par le plan france relance est ce qu on
y est est-ce que c'est du sérieux est-ce
que là il ya de l'espoir alors ça il va
falloir regarder au cas par cas et puis
sur le temps long ce que ces projets
vont donner ce qu'il faut dire déjà
c'est que dans les détails de projets
qu'on a eu on se rend compte que dans
les projets d'hydro localisation on n'a
pas forcément que des créations ex
nihilo site on peut avoir des extensions
site on peut avoir des augmentations de
volumes par
et bien une amélioration des chaînes de
production une automatisation de chaînes
de production et donc on refait revenir
des volumes de l'étranger en france dans
ses projets de france roland c'est bien
il n'y a pas que des créations petit ce
qui peut vous dire par là c'est qu'on va
pas créer 660 500 550 nouvelles usines
sur le territoire français on a des cas
très différents et ensuite il va falloir
voir ce que dans non ces projets il ya
forcément des projets qui vont être et
bien des ratés des ratés industriels il
va y avoir des erreurs il ya des projets
qui vont pas forcément arriver la
maturité nécessaire donc voyons sur le
temps long ce que vont donner
ces projets d'autant plus que l'un des
facteurs clés de la réindustrialisation
repose dans la demande série fokine
demande pour des produits made in france
dont tu vois les structurer cette
demande qui passe par trois piliers
c'est la demande via la commande
publique donc c'est tout ce que peuvent
faire les acheteurs publics en assurant
privilégier
en priorité le tissu productif national
c'est le bitoux si de btu si c'est à
dire le consommateur qui va essayer
d'augmenter sa part d'achats vers des
produits made in france qui sous-entend
d'avoir une offre de produits mais nîmes
france
existantes assez large et puis surtout
connu puis après c'est le 'b to b' donc
c'est à dire les industriels qui vont
eux mêmes se fournir vers des
industriels le français ou européens
quand il n'y a pas de solution française
et qui passe aussi par la médiatisation
mais de tout ce qu'on sait faire en
france parce qu'on sait faire beaucoup
de choses
mais finalement il ya beaucoup
d'activités qui ne sont pas ou peu
connus parce qu'elles sont réalisées par
des très petites entreprises qui sont
uniquement connue par leurs clients ou
dans leur bassin d'emploi mais
finalement pas dans toute la france
hamhuis gillis est ce que la
réindustralisation ça passe forcément
par des aides de l'état
alors oui et non j'attends dans l'absolu
un projet viable ne devrait pas avoir
besoin d'être d'état après il faut être
assez lucide on est dans un contexte
finalement international où tous les
états viennent aider leurs entreprises
d'une manière ou d'une autre donc il ya
une concurrence malgré ce qu'on dit
qu'ils se retrouvent finalement assez
fausse et si je prends l'exemple de la
chine la chine subventionne très
fortement certaines industries ce qui
leur permet aussi d'être compétitive
pour accéder à certains marchés il ya
des phénomènes de régulation dans
l'accès à des marchés ou non qu'on ne
fait pas du tout en europe il ya aussi
des sujets par exemple de la réciprocité
dans l'accès au marché puis l'aide
d'état elle peut prendre des ja l'aide
financière il ya tout le contexte qu'on
va essayer de créer pour favoriser le
développement de certaines activités
on a aussi un phénomène de retard dans
l'investissement dans nos usines que
que le plan de relance vient aider à
combler puisque on a beaucoup d'autres
qui ont été accordés aux dents au titre
de la modernisation des usines donc
c'est investir dans les nouvelles cités
unités de production en automatiser
certaines etc dans l'absolu la
réindustrialisation et devrait pouvoir
se faire sans être d'état sauf que dans
les faits eh bien il n'ya il faut
regarder comment ça se passe dans le
reste du monde et il n'y a aucun pays
qui ne subventionne pas un moment ou un
autre ses activités et notamment là où
ses clés c'est quand on parle beaucoup
de développer des start-up industriels
et basse et leur donner les moyens de se
développer et notamment dans les phases
critiques c'est à dire les phases
d'amorçage les premières années de vie
des start up et pas forcément au moment
où elle passe sur une production en
masse puisque là les appelle encore
start up mais elles ont déjà une
maturité industrielle beaucoup beaucoup
plus forte anaïs vote gillis dans votre
article publié dans les cahiers français
vous appeler l'état à pratiquer plus
d'intelligence économique et de
diplomates si économique pourquoi
pas parce qu'on se rend compte que la
france
est un peu en retard là derrière on a
été quand même on a plusieurs cas où on
a subi des influences étrangères et sur
lequel dont on n'a pas forcément su se
prémunir quand on regarde toutes les
tensions et on pressent qu'on prépare
les deux guerres qui a eu autour du cas
dits alstom alors après on pense que ce
qu'on veut du fait de ce qu'il fallait
garder alstom sous à capitaux français
ou pas c'est pas le sujet mais on s'est
retrouvé quand même dans des actions
assez agressive des etats-unis avec des
enquêtes contre l'entreprise des
salariés qui ont été arrêtés et mis en
prison aux états unis et c'est donc on
voit bien qu'il ya une capacité d'
influence de certains états la chine
fait la même chose notamment pour allait
acquérir aussi ça des entreprises
françaises ou européennes mais qui qui
vont bien dans la stratégie qu'elle
s'est donné en termes industriels et
puis on a aussi des affaires comme la
faire des sous marins où on dans la
communication se retrouve face à un état
qui sont totalement démunis par l'
annonce la rupture du contrat des sous
marins australiens donc ça pose quand
même la question un moment de comment
est ce qu'on arrive à anticiper ces
sujets comment est ce qu'on fait d'eux
de la diplomatie de la place de la
france un levier pour aller vendre nos
produits dans le reste du monde et pas
uniquement que des produits issus de
l'aéronautique et de la défense mais
d'autres d'autres d'autres sujets c'est
aussi comment on attire ces capitaux
étrangers sur le territoire français
même si on a progressé c'est toutes ces
choses qu'on doit doit retravailler
notamment pour se prémunir aussi des
influences étrangères et être capable de
protéger et de garde à capitaux
étrangers les actifs qu'on juge
stratégique pour des questions de
souveraineté ou pour des questions de
développement économique futur pour des
questions d'équilibré la balance
commerciale et bien d'autres sujets et
ça passe par l'europe
alors l'europe elle est
très c'est toujours compliqué parce que
on est dans l'union européenne qui nous
impose un certain nombre de quatre et de
contraintes notamment à travers les
traités européens on doit jouer à
l'échelle européenne et en même temps on
se rend bien compte que la construction
européenne aujourd'hui elle est plus
faite à la fois de dumping fiscal et
social en interne donc qui complexifie
la compétitivité et induit un rapport de
force entre les états elle est faite
d'un droit de la concurrence qui est
inapte au regard des besoins elle est
faite de
deux rapports de force entre les états
membres et des visions très différentes
si vous regardez la réciprocité dans
l'accès pu dans l'accès aux marchés
publics il ya des divergences très
claire dès est assurée ce qu'il faut
mettre de la réciprocité ou pas la
question de la taxonomie avec la
question du nucléaire
montre aussi à des divergences entre les
états et la taxe carbone aux frontières
également donc on se rend compte que si
l'europe est le bon échelon pour un
certain nombre de projets regard de sa
taille de marché etc la construction
actuelle est bien du fait des rapports
de force puis on voit d'ailleurs dans
les systèmes dead sur certains projets
c'est plutôt des entreprises allemandes
ou ou d'europe de l'est ce qui arrive
est la france a du mal à tirer son
épingle du jeu là dedans à jouer des
coudes à l'échelle européenne donc c'est
oui la construction européenne mais
c'est oui aussi voir tous les
contraintes qu'on a aujourd'hui qui font
qu'elle n'est pas forcément favorable au
développement de l'industrie nationale
merci beaucoup anaïs void gillis pour
vos réponses l'entretien de
l'intelligence économique est terminée
mais évidemment vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission sur france 24 points
comme au revoir
[Musique]